welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode three
an episode that spoiler warning confirms
wanda envisions bay base as
billy kaplan and tommy shepard future
young avengers wiccan and speed all
while getting agonizingly closer to
revealing what the hell is going on in
west view so i'm going to comb through
this episode shot by shot for the
interesting clues and details that you
might have missed oh and real quick i
am wearing our new lace obsession shirt
and unusual couple
available at our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com it's got easter
eggs revealed only via augmented reality
and epic hero shop is giving away 10
ps5s just subscribe to their channel
epic hero labs and
every 10 000 subscribers they'll
announce a new winner just go to epic
hero shop.com
giveaway and fill out the form to enter
these are selling out real fast get one
of these and you can write in a custom
shout out for our episodes of inside
marvel
okay after episodes based on the dick
van dyke show and bewitched episode
three's opening titles mix and
influences from 70s sitcoms
the brady bunch with a 3x3 grid on the
title
three's company with the bike writing
and the music sounds like the partridge
family theme not the come on get happy
featured in ant-man the wasp but the
theme from the first season
[Music]
and once again hexagons despite all the
other aesthetics updating through the
decades this geometric formation keeps
coming back it's the constant
now sure not every hexagon you see in
the mcu
is related hexagons are common shapes
that show up everywhere the wormhole
grid of the mcu the barrier of wakanda
the aim logo but no we are probably not
going to see the iron man 3 organization
in the same series general viewers are
trying to get to know what sword is
one dormant initiative per show people
but within one division episode to
episode there could be a connection
amongst the hexagons we see in this
series
whether it's the number six or that
honeycomb hive west view theory or
simply juandus chaos magic often being
called hex
magic and the opening on the movie
theatre marquis behind vision is
mazda great and powerful oddly a 2013
title in a 70s setting
now there could be a parallel between
one division and the wizard of oz this
series also has multiple witches a tin
man
and seems to be all about smoke and
mirror illusions and
oz the great and powerful was directed
by sam raimi who's currently directing
elizabeth olsen and doctor strange the
multiverse of madness which this series
might be setting up wanted to be the
villain of
agnes once again has her pendant which
appears to show
three figures some are saying this could
be connected to the three witches of
macbeth
i'm not sure though there's definitely a
taller one that holds something above
these two smaller ones
maybe a clue that wanda's children are
being kind of marionetted by another
entity
actually pulling the strings herb greets
vision with that same finger guns
gesture that he did last episode
interestingly herb does do a lot of with
agnes this episode and she did that same
pew pew pew gesture to the mailman last
episode
stick him up don't shoot i'm just a
messenger
vision swing set has a green and yellow
color scheme matching his wardrobe and
the colors of his classic costume in the
comics which he will show up wearing
later this series and you'll notice when
vision later swings with wanda you can
briefly see paul bettany's flesh arm
under his sleeve
vigin reads this red library book titled
pregnancy
the psychological experience by libyan
arthur coleman
it looks super worn down which is a bit
odd because it was first published in
1973 that decade this sitcom is set in
the library book should not be that
beaten up
some say that shadowy figure on the
front looks like the fist though
others say it kind of looks like
mysterio if you do think about it in
spider-man 3 set photos
is being made into this conspiracy
martyr with a bunch of other flyers for
missing children we'll see how that
connects or if it does
their new home set is modeled on the
living room the rock wall the stairs of
the brady home
wanda's hair is even fashioned like
marsha brady long straight and parted
down the middle careful wanda it is the
70s bundy is still on the loose
vision asks isn't it i mean practically
overnight i mean
how did this happen that sharp leg
squeeze we do start to see this episode
a diverging of wandas and visions
motives and their levels of cognition
wanda is far more concerned with hiding
their superhero natures and nesting
while vision seems like he's on that
same page
but he totally publicly reveals his
powers in his pursuit to figure out what
the hell is going on something that by
the end of the episode wanda doesn't
seem to care that much about dr
nielsen's kind of an idiot
we let the little ladies keep tabs on
their growing babies with fruit
makes it simple for them son of a [ __ ]
now in his fruit comparison he says at
seven months it's the size of a
pineapple
the fruit we later see wanda carving up
maybe the same pineapple agnes gave them
in episode one
it's like she knew these fruit babies
were the plan the whole time
now the doctor's headed out on vacation
bermuda baby
yes bermuda interesting destination
associated with the bermuda triangle aka
the devil's triangle
where various vessels over the years
have gone missing not
unlike the sword toy helicopter that
suddenly appeared in west view after
perhaps vanishing from the outside world
as a life-size
aircraft west view here could be the
bermuda hexagon the devil's hexagon
with a dark agenda too to use the
doctor's words make a bermuda
baby bermuda baby meanwhile herb
is glitching
this tells us herb isn't playing a part
actively to deceive them
but under a kind of spell that is
causing him to malfunction like this
it's a lot like the simulated reality in
rick and morty which also similarly
glitches
my man and in just the time he was
outside juana's pregnancy
jumps to five months judging by the
papaya he holds beside her womb like the
beeping toaster and the ticking strucker
watch
time's getting faster and faster it
isn't advancing logarithmically it's a
curved exponential acceleration in the
nursery wanda eats oranges
probably the orange that dropped off the
table in the previous scene orange
slices are kind of a thing in the mcu
scott lang mentioned them as a recharge
food after growing in civil war does
anyone have any orange slices
and his same orange slices showed back
up again an end game if you were looking
closely but they're painting with
sensor paint universe of color which is
an odd to jerry simpson
a marvel studio storyboard artist for
honda vision doctor strange multiverse
madness and she-hulk now wanda's
butterfly mobile comes to life that's
kind of fluttery
oh did i do that i didn't need to did i
do that wanda the 80s sitcom
urkelverse is until next week also wanda
is verbalizing here how she
accidentally changes the world and
brings beings to
life with just words blabbed out
something that could happen with
jose mutants but instead of no more
mutants
let there be mutants oops did not do
that now they discussed some name
options i can't wait to meet you little
bitty
billy well i was thinking tommy just a
nice classic all-american name ah
confirmed as we've speculated for the
past year
wanda's children are indeed billy kaplan
and tommy shepard
the marvel mutants and young avengers
wiccan and speed respectively their
story in the marvel comics is a little
confusing
see when wanda first has her kids in the
comics they aren't really given full
identities yet they are just kind of
revealed to be illusory pieces of
mephisto's soul and then are later
reassembled into mephisto
agatha wipes her memory but then later
wanda tries to re-materialize these kids
in house of
m and around this era in comics wiccan
and speed are introduced as
young avengers and then they're kind of
connected back as wanda's mutant
children via that mephisto link i know i
know
it looks like the mcu is simplifying
this one division
is a kind of prelude to wanda's reality
flipping and house of
m setting up future young avengers in
the marvel cinematic universe
kids who will team up with kate bishop
from the upcoming hawkeye series cassie
lang from the ant-man the wasp quantum
mania movie
and others vision quotes shakespeare all
the world's a
stage all the men and women merely
players ah this
is the famous seven ages of man
monologue from as you'd like it it's an
extended metaphor comparing the life of
a person to a theatrical performance
paralleling the central conceit of one
division
in which these avengers lives are a kind
of performative scripted routine that's
in front of an audience
and thank you to helix for sponsoring
this video sleeping on an old saggy
mattress you got from your uncle is like
wearing your uncle's clothes he is not
your size and he has terrible taste
insurance quit sleeping on your uncle's
hand-me-down mattress and get yourself a
personalized helix mattress
helix mattresses are made right here in
america and shipped straight to your
door
with free no contact delivery free
returns and a 100 night sleep trial to
choose a mattress helix made a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or one that's really firm if you
sleep on your side or on your back or on
your stomach or if you tend to sleep
really hot which i know you do
with helix there is a specific mattress
for each and everybody's unique taste i
took the quiz and got matched with the
dusk luke's helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool
i've been sleeping great ever since i
got it i love helix but you don't need
to take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
just go to helixleve.com
rockstars take their two minute sleep
quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you're gonna love it
helix is offering
up to two hundred dollars off all
mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixleve.com
rockstars that's helixsleep.com
rockstars for up to 200
off and two free pillows the kitchen
soap is labeled toy
maybe not to this whole reality is being
a bit coy reluctant to tell the truth
meanwhile over at the joneses phil reads
the newspaper with the headline two
fire hydrants added on main street
jessica actually yesterday pointed out
how the fold makes it look like the word
hydra
but the lamp is what i'm looking at it's
got these two cherubs on it remember
dottie is
for the children children that are now
in west view as
wandas twin babies billy and tommy
then this moment i think something's
wrong here wonder
yes i know what you mean the truth is
we are in uncharted yes this is an
intentional editing choice the music
changes from dead serious scoring to
cutesy sitcom crap it's kind of like
when wanda said
no and rewind westview it's the same
kind of language of video editing
it looks as though wanda again is the
one doing it notice her right before the
jump
i start from side to side as if to say
no get me out of this conversation i
can't handle the truth i also like how
in the revised cut afterwards vision
says we are in
uncharted waters much like the uncharted
waters within the bermuda triangle or
devil's hexagon let's make this a thing
maybe everything we are seeing on the
inside of this reality
is a kind of sitcom feed that wanda is
projecting out on local airwaves
that's how sword is monitoring her and
why wanda can cover up the cracks in the
form of this sort of awkward editing now
in the commercial the boy in the
background is played by wesley kimmel
nephew to jimmy kimmel who in a
preseason interview with paul bettany
gave us a clue by objecting not being
invited to the friends and family studio
taping i think it was a friends and
family
kind of once friends and family i'm an
employer
and of course the product is hydra soak
with the hydra logo on the design
pattern this is actually a fascinating
nod to another marvel tv series
agents of shield in which coulson in an
episode when he was in a simulation
called the framework
rants about hydra soap that controlled
people's minds i would have figured it
out a long time ago if it wasn't for the
mind control
soap yeah wait what that blue soap
everyone uses
hydra loads it up with chemicals it
seeps into our bloodstream
and plants false memories into our
brains they want us to believe this is a
magical place
but don't worry i'm clear i make my own
soap now
now obviously that was just a hilarious
conspiracy theory by coulson and i'm not
sure if westview is the exact same thing
as that agents of shield framework but i
do still love this parallel because
obviously wanda is in the same kind of
fictitious reality
and these commercials are giving us lots
of callbacks to her past
as a hydra lab rat find the goddess
within
is an interesting tagline maybe
reflecting wanda's role as the goddess
of this pocket reality and emerging
omega
level threat in the mcu and like the
hydra striker watch
always make time and that stark toaster
forget the past focus on the future
it's kind of another call to action for
this goddess
also in marvel lore wanda's sorcery kind
of comes from a curse from the demon god
chathan
could be tied to that jessica brought up
the interesting theory that this could
be the greek goddess of witches
kate whom wanda meets in the james
robinson scarlet witch 2016 solo series
now wanda comically tries to hide her
pregnancy from geraldine it's kind of a
meta nod to the way sitcoms will
awkwardly hide pregnant cast members
baby bumps with props and blocking now
wanda tries to
banish the stork with this red smoke
much like the red smoke used by the
wicked witch of the west but the smoke
doesn't
work suggesting that wanda's not totally
in control of this reality
wanda goes into labor and the house goes
full poltergeist the fireplace ignites
hell and notice how wanda's final scream
has this deep demonic echo to it
billy and tommy are born actually if you
think about it tommy does come out first
because he's speed baby and dr nielsen
decides to cancel his trip
i don't think we'll get away after all
small towns
you know so hard to
escape followed by vision catching agnes
and herb
did you lose power too oh sure did
but ralph looks better in the dark so
i'm not complaining you know it is
pretty much the same joke that we saw
with phil and dottie not very original
agnes
is your shadow bound husband really the
grim reaper or mephisto
herb and agnes casts doubt on gerald
dean calling her an outsider
she's new to town brand new there's no
family
no husband no home she came here because
we're all
she came in because we're all what what
are you trying to tell me
because we're all stop it ah sounds like
herb was about to say trapped or
we're all under a spell maybe even dead
i find agnes reaction interesting
because she
clearly views geraldine slash monica as
a threat and once her gone but
she also desperately does not want herb
to reveal to vision
what is really going on just yet in fact
her words stop it
are exactly what mrs hart said when she
broke down kind of like a skipping
record
stop it stop it
agnes wants to keep the view illusion
alive and she seems to exert
some control of her herb and the others
in the town to maintain that charade but
they need wanda to also want to stay
plugged in using her desire
for the children to keep her happy
meanwhile sword and monica are a threat
to that illusion they want to end it
they want to break wanda free
and free the people this town thus agnes
is apprehension toward monica
and based on wander turning on monica at
the end of this episode looks like wanda
still drinking agnes's kool-aid for
now then wanda tells monica i'm a twin
i had a brother his name was pedro
pietro maximoff quicksilver he died in
sokovian age of ultron and juan is
tapping back into this past when she
sinks a sokovian lullaby and i love how
wanda's accent reverts when she says
pietrol
and then monica thinking she has an in
here tries to connect with her
he was killed by ultron wasn't he and
this breaks wanda out of the trance
just briefly returning her to that
reality of being an avenger in that
whole mcu history but it's too early
wanda does not want that right now and
she sees that sword necklace and
connects it to the logo that she saw in
the helicopter toy on the beekeeper
she steps in threateningly and then
suddenly monica is gone
where's geraldine oh she left honey
she had to rush home wanda looks eerily
calm kind of like mia faro at the end of
rosemary's baby or that creepy boy at
the end of the twilight zone episode
after he banished the bad man
the aspect ratio widens out and we see
the exterior sword perimeter camp as
monica
crash lands outside to the monkey's
daydream believer which we talked about
in the earlier trailer breakdown
in these shots you can see the town
welcome site with logos for various
community groups including the eagle
club
and the community watch group i think
that's one vision joined it's got this
eye logo whether sword or someone else
someone is
always watching westview and if you look
closely there
is a house visible from the outside
telling us that west view
was an actual town established in the
real world before wanda's pocket reality
warped it into this sitcom illusion also
note and this is important monica's 70s
clothes do not change on the outside
suggesting that whatever changes wanda
makes on the inside of the pocket
reality
remain lasting changes to all of reality
on the outside
something to keep in mind in case wanda
happens to say let there be mutants
did i do that oh one last detail i want
to leave you with in the closing credits
of these episodes you can briefly hear
among all the scoring
the sounds of a woman wailing in sadness
so however wanda may seem right now deep
down
is a woman in distress support us by
checking out our unusual couple shirt at
new rockstarsmerch.com along with other
fun designs like a hi america shirt
follow me at eavos follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars on youtube hit
that notification bell thank you for
watching
boom did i do that
[Music]
you